Vietnam is a paradise for travelers seeking a low-budget trip...
...but with every bit of adventure.
The country has a rich history,...
...amazing ancient cultures and crafts to explore.
The famed Ha Long Bay is certainly impressive,...
...but Vietnam is really at its best when you go just a little off the beaten track.
The northern province of Ha Giang is still as pure as it gets...
...and the limestone landscapes at Tam Coc are not to miss.
The town of Phong Na is a fantastic adventure tourism hotspot,...
...home to the world's largest cave.
You can get meals for 1 to 3 dollars depending on the foods.
It will cost you at least 10 dollars per day for food.
Hostel rooms cost between 5 to 10 dollars.
You can also get a comfortable hotel room for around 15 dollars if you prefer.